هجوم مكثف بالصواريخ الباليستيه تعرضت له
العاصمه الاوكرانيه مع بدايه فصل الصيف
كما تقول الاداره العسكريه 10 صواريخ من
طراز اسكندر وجهت نحو العاصمه تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها تعاملت معها
واسقطتها في السماء الا انها احدثت اضرارا
بالغه بشريه وماديه هذا المبنى تصفه
الروايه الاوكرانيه بانه عياده طبيه ورغم
سقوط حطام الصواريخ على عدد من الاحياء من
بينها هذا الحي الذي ادى هذا الحطام الى
اضرار بالغه كما تشاهدون هذه المباني ايضا
تضررت بشكل كبير الضربات بصواريخ من طراز
اسكندر بالستيا معدله اتت بشكل سريع بعد
دقائق قليله فقط من اطلاق صفارات الانذار
وهو ما لم يمكن السكان من التوجه الى
الملاجئ خلال ذوي سفارات الانذار واحدث
هذا الضرر البشري الكبير وهذه الخسائر
وفقا ايضا ما تقوله الاداره العسكريه هذا
يعني ان الهجمات على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
لم تتوقف خلال شهر مايو فقط انما هي ما
زالت مستمره بوتيره مكثفه وبشكل يؤدي الى
اضرار اكبر واكثر على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
حسب مسعود الجزيره كيف